some people you know will say oh you
know coming in you're trying to invade
our state you're trying to colonize us
and that's not what we're trying to do
what we're trying to do is keep New
Hampshire awesome hi I'm Matt Welch for
recent TV I am in Las Vegas in Nevada at
the valleys hotel at Freedom Fest and I
am happy to be joined this morning by
Carla Garrett can that's not really how
you pronounce her last name but she's
South African so that's what we get
she's part president of the Free State
Project tell the kids at home those who
don't know what is it where did it come
from what's it doing okay so the Free
State Project is a movement to attract
20,000 libertarians to all move to the
state of New Hampshire to get Liberty in
our lifetime the way it works is you
have to sign a pledge and the pledge is
twenty thousand people once that number
is reached and where are the eleven
thousand right now then people have five
years to move to the state of New
Hampshire the cool part is people have
decided they're not going to wait so we
have over a thousand people who have now
moved which means we have 15 people who
have been elected to the State House
they're elected as what there are state
reps and the reason New Hampshire was
chosen as the state is because it's
small we can concentrate people there it
has the largest legislative body in I
believe either the world but definitely
in America so they're 400 seats yeah and
what that means is they can actually you
know most of the reps know all their
constituents you know they represent
3,000 people so it's a little harder to
like screw people over because they're
your friends and neighbors I know they
members of our political party
associated with it or they they can be
FSP people who are Republicans or
Democrats I mean the people who were
elected this round were mostly ran on
the Republican ticket the Free State
Project itself is not a political action
group so how people have explained it to
me is basically on the bus drivers so my
job is just to create a vehicle for
people to move from wherever they are to
the state of New Hampshire once people
get there they do whatever they want so
people start nonprofits you know we have
a lot of people who are into Medical
Marijuana
influence policy some guys run for state
Rep some people move to Keene and just
cause all kinds of crap with civil
disobedience um you know so whatever it
sort of floats someone's boat or
whatever their issue is they can find a
place to do what they will know it's
it's Keene right Keene is where they yes
tell us a little bit about it you know
is there like a little libertarian or
get out somewhere what is it like and
Ralph okay so I mean people move to
various parts of the state I live up
north near Dartmouth some you know
people concentrate in Manchester a lot
of the politicos are in the bigger
cities Keene itself seems to be
attracting a lot of the more Anarchy
oriented people free talk live which is
nationally syndicated radio station they
they live there and you know they
broadcast from there and it just seems
to attract you know the younger kids
maybe when they get out of college and
they go there and they do I mean we do
civil disobedience all across the state
but a lot of it seems to be focusing and
the civil disobedience is targeting what
just any and all things you know I mean
there there been various things I mean
from you know manicuring without a
license was one there was a great kid
Andrew Carroll who's actually in this
documentary that was just made about the
Free State Project he walked around with
a pot plant on his hand and went to the
police station and it was like okay I
have a bud here arrest me and they did
you know so it's just really to shine
the light on some of the ridiculous
things and it's to show the coercion of
the state you know when you're going up
against the police it does you know it
really you can capture the force you
know and then another example was you
know sometimes they'll go to court for
various things and they won't take off
their hats and the judge will arrest
them for contempt of court and lock them
up for three days and I think the most
effective way with civil disobedience is
if you can elicit an emotional response
so you want people to look at it and
think wow yeah you know what the state
is really a bunch of good how have the
locals responded to all these weird
people with anarchists
in there Oh favorably in general I mean
one of the reasons we chose New
Hampshire is because people are quite
libertarian-leaning they're you know
like my landlady is old she's 88 and she
was complaining about Obamacare and I
said yeah but you know Bush was just as
bad and she looked at me and she said
they're all a bunch of crooks so those
are sort of the people on the ground
because you know the media coverage
tends to skew towards the civil
disobedience side of things some people
you know will say oh you know coming in
you're trying to invade our state you're
trying to colonize us and that's not
what we're trying to do what we're
trying to do is keep New Hampshire
awesome you have t-shirts for that
slogan no but I since I just coined that
I think we should be my biggest
objection to the concept of the free
trade project and it's not really an
objection but if I was to have what is
it is it healthy to want to live next to
people who agree with you politically I
know it's a little creepy I see it's
awesome I mean that's the best part of
the Free State Project is that sense of
community I mean we're building the
community of course with people coming
in but then the longer we're in the
state I've been there now for four years
you start to meet people you know
through your day job or whatever where
they do agree with you and maybe on some
things not entirely but then you can
sway them you know I personally am a
voluntary estándar I want people you
know through persuasion to change
people's minds that's great thank you
very much Carla for being with us free
state project check it out libera topia
now entering a free state of minds the
newish documentary out on it for recent
TV I'm Matt Welch
you